Donald Trump is doing something
interesting on the issue of abortion now
I never believed that Donald Trump was
actually anti-abortion when he started
saying that he was during the 2016
presidential campaign and in fact Trump
didn't even claim to be against abortion
most of his life
most of trumps life he called himself
pro-choice but he came up with a reason
for his supposed abortion awakening when
he decided that he was going to run for
president as a Republican and I'm going
from memory here but it was something
about he knows someone who thought about
getting an abortion and she didn't and
then the kid was great and Trump likes
the kid so now he's against abortion and
it's totally not believable like most of
Donald Trump's explanations for how he's
reached political positions but it's
actually really smart because there are
a lot of Republican voters that are one
issue voters that one issue is abortion
and we wonder how do these evangelicals
vote for Trump even though he's had
three wives he's cheated he's paid off
porn stars and the answer is very simple
he says he's against abortion Hillary
said she was pro-choice they weren't
gonna vote for Hillary and it's as
simple as that and obviously Donald
Trump realizes that the anti-abortion
crowd just eats up anything abortion
related like it's being spoon-fed to
them and he is rewarded greatly for
touting how bad abortion is which is why
he spoke to the March for Life why he
continually talks about and lies about
abortion so in the midst of the recent
growing calls for impeachment in the
midst of the Moller report that's
devastating to Donald Trump he's
actually doing something that is really
smart to at least solidly hold his base
which is he is saying crazy things about
abortion that score him many political
points and Saturday I believe this was
Friday Saturday he held one of these
ridiculous lie riddled rallies in
Wisconsin and he said that in so-called
extreme late term abortions Democrats
are okay with the mother and the doctor
deciding after the child has been born
whether or not to execute it and if
you're watching the video I'm about to
play for you this is an aside you'll
notice that there's a black guy and what
looks to be his daughter on stage just
where they are most visible over Trump's
right shoulder and this is a staple of
these rallies consider the rallies in
Wisconsin which is somewhere between
four and six percent black depending on
which statistics you look at most of
those Wisconsin black people are not
supporters of Donald Trump but it's a
really common Republican strategy
sometimes Democrats use it too it's just
much more forced when it's Republicans
you put the rare black person that's in
the crowd for a Republican right on
stage behind the candidate in the most
noticeable and conspicuous place that's
an aside if you're watching let's get to
the video into it you'll see Donald
Trump interrupting himself for a moment
to praise former wisconsin Governor
Scott Walker who was in the crowd but
stick with it and listen to what Trump
says about abortion aggressively pushing
extreme late term abortion allowing
children to be ripped from their mothers
will
right up until the moment of birth
and just this week your Democrat
governor and by the way
[Applause]
we have Scott Walker's here
great governor he did a great job he's a
great governor can a big future but your
Democrat governor here in Wisconsin
shockingly stated that he will veto
legislation that protects Wisconsin
babies born alive born alive the baby is
born the mother meets with the doctor
they take care of the baby they wrap the
baby beautifully and then the doctor and
the mother determined whether or not
they will execute the baby I don't think
so
now this is one of those things where do
I really need to tell you that this
isn't true I mean most people realize
that what Trump is saying is just not
true and if you know that already I
don't need to tell it to you and if you
believe what Trump is saying it's so
insane that it's not going to matter if
I tell you that it's not true but this
is all completely backwards there are
not laws that allow abortions there are
laws that are attempted to be passed to
restrict the legal medical procedure
known as abortion those laws that Trump
is talking about being blocked our laws
that are about restricting access their
laws that are meant to make abortions
more difficult to get it's the standard
stuff out of the Republican playbook
would the added caveat that now with the
overwhelmingly conservative Supreme
Court they are desperate to get
something abortion related up to the
Supreme Court with the idea that they
may get a decision that they can then
allow that they can they use to further
abortion restrictions at the state level
so when Trump talks about these
so-called extreme late term abortions
those are very rare I mean late term
abortions are already quite rare
extremely term abortions are even more
rare and babies that are born alive
after abortion procedures are even more
rare than that and the babies that are
born in those cases already get full
legal protections that anybody gets I
mean there's no you don't actually need
to pass any of what Donald Trump and his
cronies are talking about here now there
are cases and did this this is horrible
there are cases when there is a
a fetus that is not viable okay it's
going to die if there is an attempt to
deliver the baby and the abortion
attempt fails and the baby is born with
a congenital defect that will maybe end
up living a few days or a few weeks and
then what happens is the doctor and the
mother have to decide do we pull the
baby off of life support or do we allow
it to stay on life support for a few
Weeke weeks living a very difficult life
which ultimately will be lost right
they're not deciding about an execution
they're deciding how quickly is the baby
going to die and it's one of the most
difficult decisions parents could ever
have to make it's one of the most vile
and disgusting ways that I can imagine
to politicize what is a horrible
situation but from a political
perspective it's really effective it's I
hate to say it but it's really effective
for Trump to do this stuff and if
Republicans sat down and looked I mean
listen if they sat down and looked at
the footnotes of the Moller report they
might say this is what Trump's been up
to this has to stop but they don't do
that and instead they go to these
rallies or watch them on TV and they
hear Donald Trump slam Democrats for
bogus positions on abortion that they
don't have and it is the epitome of
political red meat it works really well
on Donald Trump's base and it's
extraordinarily dangerous particularly
when true falsehoods are being spread
which then create violence at Family
Planning clinics they catalyze and
coalesce the angry violent protestors
that hang around around Planned
Parenthood and they put women in danger
and Donald Trump is benefiting from it
politically you can say that he's smart
to recognize that he benefits from this
politically but it's completely immoral
and it's completely unethical and he's
going to keep doing it because it's
effective from him for him for a
political from a political standpoint
it's so disheartening I wish it didn't
work but it does so I get why he's doing
it